I
love what like ethernet driver
Shenanigans it's just the best I did a
full system
upgrade hopefully the thing is
take
this and we're going to start the
wrapper
and we'll see how far we
get before I take a break to go for run
little exercise
um all right so let's see what they
do need
this
sis okay so a lot of these are
actually pretty similar to what we do
with
puffer um this is only like 200 lines
all I have to figure out basically is
how to get this into something that
looks like
this this is going to
be
Isaac g poer
m okay so there's some setup for Isaac
gem
we don't really care about this config
Shenanigans unless you can't get it from
Isaac gem which would be kind of that'd
be kind of
used not
used it's not used right is there a
super on this
nope so that means that um oh duh
there's no base class so I mean those
things literally can't do anything then
there's no domain
randomization so this is also redundant
see how much garbage they left
in I mean this is they have get States
but this never gets
populated let's see what else is in here
that's just
gross
okay that seems to actually get used
this literally just get St To
None
step you see how much garbage they just
leave in like this code
config
okay that actually does
yes we'll have to implement
that not bad
though pre physic step also not
implemented that's
hilarious so this Base Class doesn't do
anything they just had 200 lines of
garbage doesn't actually do
anything it's
hilarious they weren't so sad um
okay I guess we got to look at the other
rappers for what they do with
these okay so this this is humanoid of
Base
task and we just need
the there's some configuration it
seems to load the humanoid
in let me see where this actually
happens
cuz this is just a base environment with
nothing in it
tensors and you get the tensors
from from
there okay so I'm not understanding how
the humanoid gets loaded in
M's okay this looks like where it's uh
setting this up
reset compute observations right
here humanoid
Ops then here's the pref physics
step so actions
okay so they have to
set the tensors
here then they do the compute
observations and rewards and stuff okay
so I see how this works um this is going
to be I mean this is going to be some
substantial time to really go through
this cuz they have quite a bit of stuff
in here
in fact I think I might even
keep this structure that they have
morning I might even keep this structure
that they have and just like prune it
down a lot so we have a base
Isaac
gem
thing I might do that I have like base
Isaac gym
thing and
um I really don't like to have multiple
layers of
inherited [ __ ] is the only thing
here so like base task and puffer M and
then like humanoid a
right so we would just yeah what we
would do is we would have just the base
task this would just be Isaac or
whatever
and
okay we could do this we could just
compose these so we have uh we don't end
up with three layers of inherited
horseshit I think that's what I'll
probably do it'll be slightly
better um and we'll have this base
viewer
and I guess we don't use the setup
because these are going to be torch
tensors puff Li at the moment we don't
have native torch tensor stuff cuz most
of our MS are
CPU but I I can do the same thing I did
for GPU Drive
I should start this right now at least I
think I'm going to start this for a bit
just see if I can understand a few
things as to how you know what's working
here then I'm going to go for my run and
stuff and then I'll come back and it'll
be the whole rest of the day on
this only thing I want to check first is
I want to check our
graphs make sure our runs are working on
one I want to check our graphs on our
experiments
oh and I also probably should check the
the NYU slack to make sure they're not
going
here and this is going to
be creation
[Music]
time okay so it hasn't figured out
anything yet with the uh the current
hypers which is reasonable it's uh it's
a pretty tricky environment and it's
only got three sample so
far so we'll leave that
be yeah we'll uh we'll leave this in
so we can just do this as an Isaac end
right
gem self. m.
gy and we'll figure these out these
spaces
so they've got like this massive
configuration which I really don't
like should I go find what their config
looks like that probably a good
idea okay so they have a whole bunch of
stuff in the config
so a lot of this should just be
hardcoded because this is they're they
have a config yeah this makes no sense
they have a
config that they're loading
in like they have a humanoid environment
and then they're loading in as a config
what the humanoid environment needs
should just be in there
well at the least this isn't like a
config this is I mean this is the spec
there's nothing to
resources there's a lot of like there's
a lot of stuff in here there really is
I think I just hardcode most of
this and
um as I'm sure some of this is
redundant and then whatever actually is
a config parameter that's something that
you might actually want to
change uh I can put that in uh that can
go into the creation
function maybe these reward weights and
stuff we'll
see that's easy to do though
yeah we're going to get rid of the
config we just we want something that's
nice and
fighting yeah we are currently fighting
Isaac and actually I think that for what
I'm doing I just want this one
there
SC we're just going to manually load
this conf in and then we got this is key
bodies right
here we got already have it because good
we can set up the character props which
is
size I'm accidentally modifying their
code instead of mine
here um that's fine we'll copy this
in get OB
720p at 30
ah I can do you one better here I've got
stupid crashy Linux drivers so if the
stream goes down
randomly it's because I have not figured
out what demons have infested my nice
brand new machine preventing it from
having consistent
ethernet literally just drops my
ethernet randomly rebooting the
interface doesn't do anything no idea
what's happening
Li space
box
be why is my auto complete not
freaking there we
go action space we'll do something like
this
device uh and then they for no reason
they store this in the con cool so we
don't need
this well wait do we need this let me
say
you get rid of config
yet I did not quite get rid of
it they just have it just a
have yeah they literally don't even use
it num obs
they don't use it
either
States not
used garbage
code quick question we just
moved
from the paper to now the oral
defense we're going to be up okay phcd
student
cool anything from your defense I should
know before if I use it as an
example are you a PhD student doing your
defense or what is this
um I mean if you're I don't know if
you're asking about the content of it or
the preparation of it oh okay cool cool
um I don't know if you're asking about
the content or the preparation of it so
basically I spent the content of it I
mean the content of it is pretty much
what's there if you want a ton of
details like way more details than
anyone ever
needs uh
I got my thesis online right here so
here's 170 pages of all the work I did
over my whole PhD and uh there are the
thing is that there are little like
sections there are little sections
before all the papers that kind of put
stuff into
perspective um you know there's like
some like this is easy to get summarized
in this
format right so you can kind of there's
lots and lots of stuff this is all the
content of the whole
PhD uh the preparation of it now was I
spent very little time on my on that
actual document cuz this is basically
just all my paper slammed together with
a few extra sections this took me less
than a week um the thesis defense took
you know a good three weeks to prepare
and uh it was it's a lot
of you know it's a lot of going through
the delivery live I probably went
through that like a 100
times more for the slides oh I put no
effort into the slides um the slides are
basically well the nice Figures were
from previous presentations I gave
throughout my whole
PhD uh the like the nice figures that I
had and everything else is basically me
just sticking out how to set up timeline
for your presentation what do you mean
timeline like how to time the
detail like how did I time my
presentation so I mean b pretty much
it's I went through it so many times
that I basically knew not every word I
was going to say right but very very
closely I knew what I was going to say
um so you know the variance from
delivery to delivery was maybe a few
minutes um you know I had that thing you
really have to have your talks when it's
an important talk you really have it
nailed down to you're pretty much just
delivering exactly what you know you're
going to say in a way that's very you
know natural and not just like reading a
script know some slides can be very
quick some slides can be longer I
literally have two blank slides in my
presentation
where I just talk about stuff for a few
minutes right that's fine
too um you'll notice I don't have a
whole bunch of text on my slides I
generally like making slides with a
bunch of text is a waste of time take
all that text put the text into your
notes on the bottom of the slide and
then optimize the way in which you're
going to deliver that and just have the
visual that you were going to put on the
slide there maybe a little bit of text
sometimes but very very sparing that's
generally what I did with that it worked
very well
so that's how the thesis goes currently
what we're doing for uh the folks that
just joined on Twitch and YouTube we are
currently taking the uh Isaac Jim
physics Sim and we are trying to undo
the the generational trauma of years of
PhD students building horrible rappers
on top of each
other get something nice and simple to
load this
in it's literally like half of the stuff
in here that they had was just unused
variables and unused
configs okay this one gets
used but then it's like you just pass
it contr fre
inverse two
now we're just doing you know we're
cleaning up this code so we can actually
do something with
device what the heck
now this is going to be
device equals
Cuda and then you can pass it a specific
GPU if you want this is
device
if graphics
device does this get us this doesn't get
used it doesn't get
used does device get used you got to
tell me device gets used
right yeah okay this does get used it
looks
like in create
Sim wait but they don't pass anything to
this
hold on compute
device let me see
something maybe I mess something up with
this
oh yeah if um you're looking for another
talk by the way to look
at this one did not do as well on
YouTube but I actually I think that the
delivery of it was better than my uh my
thesis defense
it's also just a really good reference
for um for
RL right here this
one I'll link this in the chat this is a
really good reference if you're looking
to just get like a picture
of all of like reinforcement learning
what we're doing with it you know where
it's going this is I made this video for
that I'm not doing more of those cuz
they take a ton of time and basically if
they don't blow up massively it's just
really not worth it but
um yeah
it's it's a pretty nice reference
how does this work I'm me see I messed
this up with the phys
s okay well this code doesn't run
because
look they don't call it with parameters
so I don't know what the heck is up with
that so presumably this is some janky
super class
thing um because there yeah there's no
way this code runs
aha you
see so this is where this gets
created and this takes a bunch of stuff
so physics
and this is uh okay so they specifically
have so we can make this very easily
this is
fine and
then ah Sim f
x so this is quite easy we just
do this is physics engine
equals gy API that's Sy physics
I don't like that I have to
these maybe I'll just pass
it yeah maybe I'll
here6 engine
equal gem
X there you
go and now when we do create
Sim we can
pass physics engine and then the last
thing is going to be Sim
configure args which
is 60.0
device
this is
good and then if Sim in config
default SIM options are provided in
config okay so we have to add some stuff
to
this and I
believe args
per and there we go it's they're right
here so physics num thread
four subes is
zero client threads is
zero okay so we got all this now we need
to figure out the
SIM
here let's see where they pass the
uh make n so they pass RS
make
and and
[Music]
then par Sim prams args
config load yaml and config file okay so
it should all be in the end config
what is an Isaac Jimson config is there
are there docks on this thing or is it
just
they don't have freaking
docks
ah
jeez deprecated no dos figure it out
yourself all right
yeah oh it's dot I
see okay that's
easier yeah yeah yeah okay that's way
easier okay so then all we have to do is
you just put these in order so num
threads
SRX dot solver type is
one position veloc eration
okay I'm starting to see why they have a
config for all this
crap should I consider that maybe I was
wrong and there there's too much stuff
here and this should be loaded from
config let me
think I just really don't want to deal
with path issues
okay also the other problem is the way I
have puffer set up if I need to sweep
any of
these they actually do need to be set
like this because I can just add them
easily from here to the init function
and then sweep them so I think this is
actually going to be fine should just do
it this
way so we do physics so these are the
physics Brams and then uh it should be
just from
extras I guess these go up here maybe
we'll put them like this and
Sim
Flex in
there and
and that's it okay that's not
bad this is all that they've
got this goes up the
had a cool idea for uh NYU
folks send some stuff I I keep like
slacking stuff open on the side so
whenever you see me like go over and
look at something it's just some DMS or
whatever I mean nothing super sensitive
most of the time but it's just like as a
courtesy I try not to leak like lab
slack messages and stuff
not not a huge deal
really um okay we get to get rid of this
finally
okay and then the only thing else we
need is simp
Ram which we now
have uh also this function is freaking
stupid because look at this it's tiny
and what did I I have
here
oops ah messed up hold on
take
this put it
here and we do
device Graphics this is Graphics device
not graphics device
ID so this
is so we're going to do this is Graphics
device
Sim
this me just prepare the
Sim one more stupid function deleted
it's good
this does not get
called does not get
cold let's
whoops let's see if it gets cold
somewhere
else so much redundant
[ __ ] drive you
crazy basically the other guy that I
have working on this has just been so
damn confused because all this code
sucks and say I don't blame him I'm
trying to spend
today
cleaning generations of PhD submitted
garbage set Sim commands up access does
not get called does it get called in s
uh in is hoi set Sim
Rams okay they do call it here um they
call it before they call create
Z so what we're going to
do is
there's no reason it would ever not be
Z s. up AIS idx two in case we need
this up and AIS
index and they do use this
here yeah but that's dumb it's
just we'll just do
this
here okay anything else that we've got
here that we don't need so we've got
create Sim which we already have gotten
rid of so this is gone step obviously we
need these are like weird API things
we'll get rid of and render Okay so
we've actually we've cut this thing down
quite a
lot we've cut this thing down quite a
lot um the next things are going to be
to integrate and I started messing with
uh with stuff over here right
next thing is going to be to start
configuring the humanoid version of the
environment figuring that
out but we made some good progress um
I'm going to call stream for the morning
and I'm going to be back in the
afternoon after I get some exercise get
some food do a few things and then I'll
be here all afternoon working on this uh
this Sim and depending on how long it
takes possibly tomorrow as well possibly
not we will see about that um for the
couple folks that are still watching
here if you're interested in puffer lib
if you're interested in getting involved
with RL
Dev all the stuff is on puffer
doai all of Rems are online you can
watch them played by agents you can play
them yourself we've got docs we've got
articles including for
newcomers and if you want to help us out
for free start the repository really
really helps out can join the Discord
this is where we organize all the dev if
you're interested in getting involved
and you can follow me on X I post a
whole bunch of RL stuff including some
articles you can't find anywhere else so
thank you all very much